this is a production of Cornell
University well thank you very much
Don for that nice introduction and this
afternoon I am going to go back to
Haudenosaunee territory and talk about
the three sisters as a cropping system
well known with the with the Iroquois
but this is a cropping system not only
present here in the Northeast
it is a cropping system all over the
Western Hemisphere and as Carl Sawyer
wrote in 1962 it's a symbiotic plant
complex of North America without an
equal elsewhere for the Iroquois william
fenton
has indicated that it is the foundation
of Iroquois subsistence enabling them to
develop institutions of sedentary life
well the three sisters in terms of their
origins in in the Northeast until quite
recently most archaeologists and
anthropologists thought that these three
crops arrived in the Northeast as a as
an intact cropping system and that they
came here sometime between 1000 and 1200
1200 BP but recent work by the
paleobotanist John Hart who works at the
New York State Museum at Albany has put
forth a much different you know story
first edible squash has been around here
since 3000 BP maize by 20 to 70 BP and
beans a much more recent introduction
700 BP or just um in the you know couple
hundred years before Europeans arrived
so Hart says that the
plants as a at that as a crop complex
we're not all here at the same time
until around 700 BP Oh before present
right so it archaeologists use this I it
doesn't make any sense to me because
president is always changing why would
you do that I don't get it but if the
archaeologists have a reason for it and
I'm trying to be a good archaeologist
someday so I use what they use right
well the three sisters in Iroquois 'or
in nashoni areas territories have been
central to our cultural identity in our
oral texts such as the creation story
and the words that come before all else
in all aspects of social and you know
political institutions and in
subsistence and of course women were the
farmers in the Iroquois and women
controlled most aspects of agricultural
work in the the top right you see a
watercolor painting by Ernie Smith at
Seneca artists in the 1930s portraying a
very typical Iroquois view of the plants
they're portrayed as as members of the
family as women and the difference
between the plant and the human beings
is not discernible right there they're
there one we also see another painting
below by buyer Nesmith showing this one
was called corn gathers another one of
this painting showing women bringing
corn in from the field and the drawing
on the left was by a Jesuit up in 1600s
who was along the st. Lawrence with
Iroquois and villages and farmers up
there and this was one of the drawings
that he made of women working in the
filled with handheld hoes in terms of
the agronomic characteristics of the the
three sisters they're typically planted
on mounds and this is a to see there is
a photo from early 1900s in eastern in
western Massachusetts and this was
thought to be an old Indian planting
field the crops were usually planted as
a polyculture but not always there are
indications that there were sometimes
corn monoculture zorbing monocultures
and sometimes I think even pumpkin
monocultures there were no plows in this
cropping system it was hand hand tools
only it was continuously cropped meaning
this was a permanent agriculture not
shifting cultivation the primary reason
for that is where most of this
agriculture was taking place which is
along the the center of New York State
present-day New York State and this is a
band of fruit of alpha cells which are
highly fertile this is where most of our
best agriculture is even now so the
continuously cropped means that these
were on very highly productive fertile
soils when we think about shifting
cultivation that is a a management
strategy for acid in fertile soils and
so not applicable here at this time in
terms of the agricultural productivity
of this system historic records provide
a very extensive record of firsthand
observations that date all the way back
into the 1680s even earlier indicating
that iroquois negra culture was highly
productive people were amazed that the
types of crops that they were seeing but
no one took any yields so we have no
measures of corn bushels of corn per
acre which has an agricultural
scientists that's what I'm always
interested in so back in the middle
nineteen
90s decided to do some field research
and to get some numbers so we carried
out some experiments at the musgrave
research farm up in Cuba County and on a
private farm in Tompkins County and as
much as we could we used proprieties and
agronomic practices similar to what the
Iroquois would have used in the 17th and
18th centuries I'm going to show you
some quick crop yields this was at
Tompkins County averaged over two years
and these are the three sisters meaning
the wrong way no liking that
okay
so these are the the three sisters the
crops corn beans and squash corn and
green being in in orange and pumpkin
yellow a corn by itself being by itself
and pumpkin by itself so that's what
happened in in Tompkins County over two
years in Cayuga County it looked quite a
bit different the three sisters almost
no corn
almost no beans or pumpkin higher yields
the corn monoculture about the same
being monoculture pretty dreadful and
pumpkin monoculture equally dreadful all
right
what agronomists do one of the problems
with yields like this trying to compare
pumpkins with corn is you can't do it it
really doesn't make any sense
so what agronomists do we use something
called land equivalency ratios and what
we do is we simply look at the ratio of
each one of the crops in the polyculture
and compare it to when it was grown in
monoculture so for example the corn
yield in Tompkins County in 1993 was
1874 in the three sisters and 22:31 when
it was grown as a monoculture meaning
that we basically got 82 percent of the
yield in the three sisters compared to
when it was grown as a monoculture we go
down and do the same thing for beans
132 in the in the three sisters versus
1096 we only got 12% of the yield which
we look at the pumpkins
14400 65 to over 40,000 we got about a
third what we do is we add up those
ratios and we get a number 1.3 that's
the land equivalency ratio and anytime
the number is over 1 what intercropping
people say is that it was an advantage
to have planted it as a polyculture he
the number is less than 1 it says you
should have stuck with monocultures
right so we can look at Tompkins 1994
1.08 cube in 1997 1.16 much of the poly
culture intercropping you know
literature will show results like this
although sometimes the yields are less
we get alley ARS less than 1 but in this
particular examples they're all over 1
all right
I've just been talking about crop yields
and the title is what did they eat right
so I'm interested in food values and I'm
focusing on two things energy and
protein and the reason for this is that
subsistence farmers will first ensure
that they can actually feed their
families that they families won't starve
and so what they do is they look to
produce energy their next priority after
their making sure people aren't starving
is to increase the quality of the diet
by adding protein so as a consequence of
this most subsistence farmers will plant
a grain like wheat maize rice for energy
calories and a legging like bean pee or
lentils in order to add protein but I'm
back to this question again because
before we go any further we have to be
clear about what we're talking about
here what did they really eat now I've
given lots and lots of workshops to
little fourth graders all around
Compton's County with my kids and then
with lots of other people's kids right
and almost every time after we do a
workshop on the three sisters some
little kid will come up and grab my arm
and say but what did they really eat
because they're thinking corn sweet corn
and green beans and pumpkins and it's
hard to imagine making a real meal out
of that so always the question what did
they really eat
well it is confusing because corn we can
harvest it when it's in mature green you
notice the stalks are green the the
husks are green and if you pull back the
husk that kernel is going it's if you
pinch it it will squirt milk into your
eye and we call this sweet corn right so
that's one way corn they amaze but we
also have they amazed that looks like
this and this is mature corn right
notice it's brown the stems are brown
the leaves are brown notice the ears the
husks are brown and notice how different
the kernels what right there hard this
is green corn right we can do the same
thing for beans this is Daisy Olas
Bulgaria's a kidney bean we can harvest
it when it's a mature green the leaves
are green the pods are green slice open
the pod right we see a little tiny seed
in there but we're eating that whole pod
but we could leave the plant in the
field let it fully mature notice
everything's turning brown now we
harvest a pod but we take out the seeds
inside there and we eat those no longer
interested in that pot well that this
has major effects on the nutrient
content of these foods so for example
sorry
if we eat if we harvest maize as sweet
corn 75% of it is water
it has 86 calories and 3 grams of
protein but if we wait and harvest it as
mature grain its only 10 percent water
3650 calories and 9 grams of protein
what happens with green bean is even
more striking harvest it when it's green
90% water 31 calories 2 grams of protein
wait until it's mature we call it a
kidney bean 12 percent water 33 70
calories and 30 grams of protein so you
can guess if you're a subsistence farmer
when you're going to harvest your crops
predominantly particularly if you're
worried right maybe you don't have
enough you're going to be harvesting
mature grain and mature beans so corn
grain and and dried beans all right but
now we want to go from a crop yield to a
food yield and it turns out this is a
fairly complicated process it's not so
easy so I'm bringing back this this data
from the field experiments but now I've
averaged over sites and over years and
we're looking at crop weights at harvest
weights not dry weights more or less at
harvest weights and
the maze is at 10% water the beans at
12% pumpkin flesh at 90 pumpkin seed at
five noticed here now I've divided the
pumpkin into the flesh and the seat so
now if we look at these crop weights at
harvest we see the three sisters these
are just weights over the the years but
look at this pumpkin right I mean if
you're just thinking about weight you'd
say well we should just go with the
pumpkins there's more of that than
anything else but the problem is that
most of that pumpkin is water and water
has neither calories nor protein so if
we're interested in its food value we've
got to figure out a way to get rid of
the water and fare it and compare it
more more fairly so we convert the
harvest weight to energy and protein and
the ways that we do this is we look at
the USDA nutritional database which
gives us the amount of calories
in maze this is when it has 10% water so
we've got maze 36 50 kilograms per
calories per kilogram and 94 grams of
protein per kilogram being very similar
to maze but a lot more protein about the
same amount of water pumpkin flesh only
260 calories 10 grams of protein and an
awful lot of water right pumpkin seed
whoa five thousand five hundred ninety
calories 302 of grams of protein and
only five of water
well now we're beginning to see some
differences in how we might begin to
compare these different systems so in in
this graph what I'm showing is the three
sisters here and this is the total
calories coming from maize the bean
pumpkin seed and pumpkin flesh and
notice the amount of energy there it's
actually more than what we get from
maize monoculture it's way more than we
get from being monoculture and it's a
lot more than what we get from pumpkin
but note also that a huge amount of the
pumpkin calories is coming from the seed
right now you might want to remember the
land equivalency ratio and how that even
with just the weights showed us that
even with the three sisters
we got an Ellie are of slightly over one
compared to the corn monoculture right
so we know that we can we can do better
and the energy reflects that I just
brought this up to show you and remind
you again right we'll go on we can do
the same thing with protein right so
this one we're looking at protein in the
three sisters in maize monoculture in
being monoculture and in pumpkin
monoculture right and notice the
significant contribution from the beans
and the pumpkin both flesh and seeds and
notice that it is now quite a bit higher
than maize monoculture and still higher
than the bean and still higher than
pumpkin but many of you are saying but
wait a minute
plant proteins are incomplete
so those how can you really be measuring
the proteins because we know that plants
don't provide all of the essential amino
acids that we need right so they have
different amounts and that is absolutely
true let's look at the the the maze of
being the pumpkin seed and I put pumpkin
flush up here too these are the
essential amino acids and what we will
notice is that four of these isoleucine
lysine 3:09 and tryptophan corn in
particular is low in these and being
nicely complements where the maize is
low and surprisingly the pumpkin seeds
are really strong in some of those areas
as well probably asking but these
numbers on the pumpkin flesh they're so
small right why do you even include them
well there's a lot of pumpkin flesh and
when you add up all of those amino acids
they can complement the amino acids in
the other plant foods or from other
foods whether it's fish or or nuts or
deer they can be part of the protein
contribution even though the
concentration is so small
I was also interested in looking at
calcium vitamins A and C and niacin and
these again are taken from the USDA
nutrient database what we see DEP sorry
what we see down at the bottom is a
recommended daily allowance so for
example for calcium we need a thousand
and when we look here we see well we're
now looking so good right not very good
numbers here for any of these these
foods if we look at vitamin A well maize
and beans are dreadful
but pumpkin flesh whoa we need 5,000 and
when we get 8500 and a hundred
milligrams vitamin A is not going to be
a problem right vitamin C however huh we
need 60 and we're pretty low right and
niacin we need 15 and this doesn't look
so great either all right we'll come
back and talk a little bit more about
this this wonderful word nixtamalization
it's a word that means it's a way of
preparing corn corn grain that it is
soaked and usually cooked in an alkaline
water a solution in Iroquois ax we cook
it in hardwood ash right Nixon lusatian
does a number of really neat things the
very first thing is it dramatically
reduces cooking time because the
alkaline solution attacks the pericarp
of maize which is very very hard and it
begins to hydrolyze it so that water can
get in much more quickly and so it
dramatically reduces cooking time but
the other thing that nixtamalization
does all of those ashes have lots of
calcium and what happens is the calcium
gets attracted to
starch grains and so the calcium content
of the of the corn or the maize
increases a hundred to four hundred
percent the nixtamalization also
improves protein while quality and it
does this remember the the amino acids
and I showed you a bunch of them that
corn was really deficient in that's
lysine tryptophan histidine methide and
309 so it increases the relative amounts
of of these amino acids so the end
result is its it makes corn a higher
quality protein meaning it doesn't have
yes
exactly the same yes exactly the same
it's just a difference in what you're
doing what you're using to make the
alkaline you know solution so so when we
Nick symbolize corn we actually improve
its protein quality because we balance
out some of the ore we increase the
amounts of some of those amino acids
which are very low but it also has
another impact in that it increases
niacin which is part of the vitamin
b-complex preventing pellagra Plager is
a really ugly terrible disease that was
rampant in the southeastern US in the
early 1900s it is still widespread in
parts of Africa and Asia and it comes
from primarily a diet that is almost
exclusively corn and the problem with
the corn is that it's low in tryptophan
and tryptophan is a precursor to forming
niacin right so when you Nick simal eyes
you increase the tryptophan and that
increases the niacin right before
colonization there was not a single
documented case of pellagra in the
Western Hemisphere it was only after
that pellagra came and much of it has to
do with the process of nixtamalization
because when the poor folks in the
southeastern United States were eating
corn
they were mostly just grinding it and
not nixtamalization
they had no beans either and the same
thing is true in parts of Africa and
Asia it's this is a disease of poor
people who do not have the technology
the nixtamalization or any kind of
legumes in order to increase the quality
all right so we've talked about all
these comparisons and I've told you how
wonderful the three sisters is compared
to the monocultures of maize and and
being and pumpkin although I'm sure many
of you are noting hope this Mays
monoculture in both energy and protein
maize is amazing right it really is hard
to beat maize out yields every other
grain crop it is just pretty spectacular
as Margaret Smith here is nodding away
but so I've been I've been comparing the
three sisters with a maize monoculture
of being monoculture in a pumpkin
monoculture and what I am implying is
Iroquois farmers would choose to plant
the three sisters or no we're not going
to plant our field to the three sisters
this year we're going to plant a bean
monoculture there's no way that would
happen it's not a choice between
planting your field to the three sisters
or deciding just to plant pumpkin I mean
they know that's not gonna work right I
mean it doesn't make any sense right
you're not going to decide between three
crops and one crop for your entire field
right rather you're going to take your
field and I couldn't make this into a
square right so so pretend that the the
the field is is a circle right so
instead of planting the three sisters we
might decide to plant one third of the
field to corn one third to beans and one
third to pumpkin right so instead of
having the three sisters over the entire
field we divided it into three parts and
put one crop here but it's still on the
same field right it's still what's a one
hectare right so one-third of the
hectare is corn one-third is being
one-third is squash right or we could
decide seeing how productive the corn is
I'm going to put half of it half of the
field
into corn and I'm going to put 25% into
being and 25% into pumpkin or I really
say buy that corn is looking awfully
good I'm gonna put eighty percent of the
corn of the field into corn and only ten
percent into being and pumpkin right
this is a much more realistic comparison
of what people would actually choose the
decisions that farmers are making so now
let's look at monoculture mixtures
versus the three sisters so this first
one and we're looking at energy so this
first one says we've got a third right
we've got a third of these crops and
this is how much each one of these the
maize being and pumpkin contribute to
the total energy right well it's looking
not so great right if we look at the one
that's 50% corn and then 10% add 25 and
25 being in pumpkin we can see the we're
doing better but it's still not great
when we put 80% into corn we're doing
better if we plant the whole field to
corn were even better right
forget the pumpkin in the squash or you
end up beans right just play a corn but
now look at the three sisters right when
we plant the corn and we add the bean in
pumpkin we get a jump in the amount of
energy that's the land equivalency ratio
that we saw in the yield as well but we
see it in energy too right we see that
yeah there's a good reason why these
farmers are planting the three sisters
because it turns out that we get more
energy from this than anything else we
can look at the same thing in terms of
protein but it looks different right
first of all we look at the one-third
one-third one-third and we can see we're
getting about a third from men from
maize a little bit more than a third
from the pumpkin and something less than
that from the beans but the total amount
is still less than what we get from the
three sisters and every time we increase
the amount of corn we increase the
amount of protein all right it goes up
and we get right up to there when we go
all corn but notice the significant
impact of the three sisters on
increasing protein now I would argue
that this is the major advantage of the
three sisters not so much in terms of
energy it does give extra energy but
it's really the protein so all of these
are on the same piece of land right and
we've just varied whether it's three
sisters or the others Mario this one oh
the mixture I mean these are all this is
it's the standard thing right I'm when
you're asking what portion of this most
of the yield is coming from the corn
whether it's protein or energy but if
the fact is that this is on one piece of
land so exactly where it comes from
doesn't matter right
I mean you plant three kernels of corn
in the hill and two or three of beans
and you plant the the pumpkin in between
what you're interested in is what comes
out right of what the yield is in terms
of energy and protein right
all right one last question that I'm
interested in is what how many people oh
and I'll tell you how I got started on
this I got called by the Museum of the
American Indian in New York City the
National Museum but not the one in in
Washington it's its other site in New
York City and they are doing a program
educational program on the three sisters
and they wanted to have a cropping game
in which young kids and their families
would plant different amounts either as
polycultures of the three sisters or as
monocultures and they wanted to make it
real and they said well how many people
could could it feed you know like an
acre of the three sisters right and I
said oh well I'll have to do some
calculations and I did some quick quick
back of the envelope calculations and I
I realized it was a very interesting
question
about how many people could actually eat
off of a hectare of the three sisters
right and so in order to make this kind
of calculation you first have to
determine well what are the daily
requirements of an active adult for
energy in other words how many calories
do we need and what about protein so on
a daily basis 2500 calories per day is
pretty realistic 60 grams of protein
realistic you just multiplied by 365 and
you come up with what one person would
need for a year close to a million
calories right to provide basics and 22
kilograms of protein right and then I
just go back to the data that I just
showed you and kind of divide it out so
people supported by monoculture mixtures
the ones I was showing you before and
the three sisters in this case the
energy is in the lighter kind of tan and
protein is in the the darker color and
what we see is that on everything in the
third
we've able to feed probably seven people
per hectare in terms of energy supply
that in terms of protein we get over ten
right notice that is each time the corn
goes up each of these numbers increases
so we're up to without with the
monoculture of corn we're up to about
twelve and a half people fed per hectare
in terms of energy and about 13 and a
half in terms of protein but once again
the three sisters in terms of energy we
could supply for about 13 people and in
terms of protein about fifteen and a
half just for comparison to think about
it and I have these figures and could
actually do it but I didn't guy would
have time today if we looked at European
wheat growers in the same time period
wheat farmers in Europe we're struggling
to feed even three or four people per
hectare right and so what we see here is
a cropping system that is multiple times
more productive and able to support more
people alright so what are the
conclusions here first that intercropped
Amaze being in pumpkin is highly
productive and it certainly could have
been counted on to largely satisfy
hardness show any dietary needs there
are no indication that they did that
they used only these crops in fact many
many other sources of food in in this
area a very very productive ecosystem
with all sorts of other plants you know
wild plants lots of animals and fish but
certainly as the foundation for their
diet it was doing a great job one of the
reasons for this is
it is the anchor of the system and with
its very high crop yields it produces
really enormous amounts of energy and a
lot of protein the three sisters as a
cropping system provides more energy and
protein than individual crop
monocultures and more than monoculture
mixtures of these three crops the
pumpkin in the bean and pumpkin seeds
increase the total amounts of protein
and improve protein quality the pumpkin
flesh provides lots of vitamin A and
maize nixtamalization decreases cooking
time increases calcium 100 to 400
percent improves protein quality and
increases niacin preventing pellagra if
we're looking at how many people we can
support three sisters and I have to
qualify this these are based on yields
from field experiments right and the
amounts the maize yields I am absolutely
confident in these are very realistic
maize yields in either the polyculture
or when planted as a monoculture these
are very realistic yields the beans and
the pumpkin much less experienced and
only a couple of sites and and years so
I have much less confidence in the beans
and pumpkin but it's pretty clear to me
that even with relatively small amounts
small yields of beans in pumpkin the the
three sisters does a great job because
even though small amounts boost things
enough to significantly increase energy
and and protein so in terms of energy
enough for thirteen point four people
per hectare per year and in terms of
protein almost 16 people per hectare per
year so with that I'm open to questions
the explanation for the over yielding
mostly the nitrogen from the beans are
not no I mean I would say that the
contribution of means in terms of
nitrogen to the bottom system is very
minor and the reason for that is that
people which are what contains most of
the nitrogen there are small amounts of
nitrogen and the status of the leaves
but right and once you eat it the only
way it gets back onto the field right
so the bean contribution is is
relatively unimportant I think the
reason for the extra for the increased
productivity at least one in the
literature on intercropping tells us
it's just increased efficiency of the
entire system in other words the three
crops are collecting more something like
a from energy they're gathering more
water their roots are
more water and nutrients underneath and
as a result of that we're seeing small
efficiencies that result in somewhat
greater yet can you say anything about
how
yeah
not tortillas the Cornyn and primarily
in in soup and bread the person to look
for that - two major sources one is -
Carter air Cuevas amazement
and his contemporary waa-waa
in each and I think it's just called
your quarters
very extensive discretion
Jane the carpet that you have spoke
about this pocket was that the sole
keeper the money that the Honda Show
made news now there is indications of
particular deck at the time of
Sullivan's campaign that there were lots
of different types of purpose
in terms of their complexity and I say
so and those are crops that have lightly
colored flesh quite firm right so it
looks like a pumpkin or what we would
often think of as a winter squash but
the eight corn is in a different place
right even though it point if we think
of this and we just watch the eight corn
is not or something like that anyways
but there were other turbines that were
much more similar to like a melon and
English you know about because they seem
to solvents kind of give them things
that sounded like so they might have
been growing lots of others but I
focused from the family
or the winter squash in the process of
mixed utilization I'd expect some
nutrients to be lost in the solution but
they're also picking up calcium you have
any information
well about mixed civilization that I did
learn which surprised me was that the
total protein actually decreased it's on
the corner the total amount of protein
of Nixon's corn is less but the reason
but and I think some of that may not I'm
not even sure how that happens but the
protein quality increases substantially
right so that more than compensates but
in terms of other things that might be
lost in terms of leaching I didn't see
anything and I've read it a number of
papers on mix causation and I don't
recall them saying that things were lost
other than protein
I know that okay
watch indeed also
yes short answer yes on the squash was
domesticated at different times in
Eastern woodlands in North America and
in Central and South America but the
first squashes that were domesticated
Wars and so then there there is a point
as far as I understand the edible
you know squash comes in quite a bit
late I
but again I'm not sure that the end of
the squash may have been only
domesticated in Central American and
forth because what was domesticated in
the Eastern woodlands was in
see
elsewhere like such and in Mexico quit
the accident absolutely as Carl Sawyer
said it's across the entire western
hemisphere at least up into kind of
southern Canada it goes all the way down
I'm not sure probably not for room yes
okay so it's all over
sometimes they only use two but most
come with the same where the creases are
being grown in the same place year after
year did that system require fertility
issues this is a great question and I
will send you an article on says yes I
mean they were not grown indefinitely
because your acquaintance villages were
moved frequently it used to be the
standard kind of rationale given was
that the soils
oh that's not true
the soils didn't that become depleted
primarily because the Iroquois did not
use plastic and they were starting on
very fertile soils emphasize the major
loss of fertility in agricultural
systems is not from cropping it's from
plowing which causes oxidation of
nitrates and most of those nitrates
leave the soil system only a few are
captured in life at the product when you
plow continuously which Europeans and
u.s. settlers it for a couple of hundred
years you will see a dramatic decline
so if it always been assumed that the
reason for that was these cops were just
grabbing out all of that nitrogen but
that's not true the major reason for the
decline in fertility was the continuous
cloud so the fact that the Iroquois were
growing crops starting with very fertile
soils alpha cells typically won't have
unplowed 4 to 5 percent nitrogen if you
don't publish the only thing that you
are losing then is what's taking up by
the crop small amounts when you're
digging out there with your pole don't
get captured by the groups but the
decrease in soil organic matter and in
nitrogen is very very small right so
from what we can see the Iroquois were
not
you know cutting back trees and looking
for new fields everywhere once they get
clear the field informed those mounds
they probably stayed there for as long
as the village state and the village
move not because of soil fertility
defined but because of trade means of
defensive means of the longhouse was
invested which please I mean whatever
their reasons to move but it had nothing
to do with declining soil
I know I'm sure that they had I mean
that my guess is that the
I mean the the thing that I would think
would be the biggest
and the reeds we could never grow the
three sisters at the Musgrave farm or
any place else without the and the two
reasons for this one is because we are
in we're using clocks and so when you
lose plows you're constantly bringing up
the wheat seeds and encouraging leads to
you know germinate in seconds a lot of
the needs that our most inner
troublesome now in New York State are
imports from
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu